he is none other than Mike Breen back
here on the Rich Eisen show joining us
on the day that the Warriors have yet
another parade how are you Mike well I'm
not fresh that's for sure
very nice so are you convalescing I mean
how do you unwind after a long post II
just woke up about an hour and a half
ago
I have looked pretty much the last 72
hours so you're living like a cat right
now is because yes exactly no it's you
know disappointed rich that that the
series couldn't have been more
compelling there were a couple of
terrific games but we always root for
seven games in every series we do so was
disappointed in that but that also goes
to show that the excellence of the
champions so I want to give you the
floor on this because I'm sure you hear
it all the time and I'm sure you'd like
to speak on it because I know I would
those who say that the NBA creates
situations to make sure it's not a sweep
and it's a seven-game series for
broadcasters like you Mike you have the
floor on that it's just silly but I I
understand being you know a sports fan
myself when I root for my team or
sometimes as passionately root against
another team I don't like I lose all
objectivity I become somebody who's
irrational and that's what sports fans
do so I'm ok with it they want to say
that that's fine
but it's just it's silly especially
today's day and age with the scrutiny
and the spotlight that's on everything
from coaches to players to officials it
just it can't happen I'm sorry I'm and
again I understand I'm with you as a
fellow passionate sports fan I
understand how you can become delusional
but it's just not happening so when you
mentioned Mike about moments during the
finals that were seminal and certainly
ones that will live forever there's no
question the end of game one is exactly
that what walk me through your mindset
as you're calling the action as jr.
Smith gets that rebound of the George
Hill free throw miss at the end of game
one
well from from a broadcasting standpoint
you say to yourself you've been doing
this a long time and just when you think
you've seen everything a few things pop
up that you haven't seen now the Junior
Smith thing believe believe it or not as
the knick announcer I have seen that
before
no oh yeah he did it at the knick game
he didn't know the score at the end of
the game and he took a shot quickly
mm-hmm
because he didn't realize that the score
was tied he thought they were behind and
he took a shot quickly in and the team
the Rockets went up getting a getting a
rebound going down he could have you
know taken time off the clock the shot
clock was off instead the opponent the
Rockets I got the rebound went down the
other end went up winning a game so he
has done that before so that I have seen
but just the whole process of everything
going through it was crazy as for the
just from a basketball standpoint you
know you could see this game slipping
away or you it had that feel obviously
that it was slipping away from Cleveland
who were as big an underdog as we've
seen in a while in the finals and there
they are in Game one with a chance to
get this series turning victory and I
always look at you know the players at
that time in the body language and the
you could almost see them resign to the
fact and I remember watching an overtime
in the huddle and this was before that
big video was released of just focusing
on LeBron James
they looked defeated walking to the
huddle you got the feeling that there's
no way they're gonna recover from this
and then they didn't for the rest of the
series with the exception of a game
three that appeared to be in the cards
for Cleveland for various reasons being
at home and the way that they were
playing and then Durant shut the door
personally on that front and it's just
remarkable how he makes the three from
the same spot and the same floor and
back-to-back years Mike that was an
unbelievable performance that night he
he is in a short time and this included
that 2012 finals when OKC lost to Miami
in five games
he was great in those finals his numbers
that he's putting up in the finals games
or off the charts in terms of what he's
scoring how efficiently he's scoring and
doing other things as well so you know
we always talk about the players who
rise to the occasion when it's the
biggest moment he is right there you
know he was made for this he's lived for
this and he's embraced it and excelled
at it it's it's so impressive to watch
Mike Breen here on the Rich Eisen show
after calling the NBA Finals on ABC ESPN
on ABC here on the Rich Eisen show in
the years that you've been in or though
I guess the last couple years or this
year in particular that you were in any
of the production meetings would Steve
Kerr any of these players did you get
any sense of what David West Shaun
Livingston a bunch of players were
referring to after the finals were
concluded that that there was some drama
behind the scenes that we would be
shocked that the Warriors were able to
overcome not that there was drama that
would shock you but all season long you
sensed that it wasn't the same that this
year was hard and it was more of enos's
human nature they weren't as focused
they weren't as committed defensively
they weren't as quick to move the ball
which you know to me that's natural for
teams that have played in so many big
games so during the course of the season
you know he kept here in the phrase well
if we can be able to just flip the
switch so you knew there was frustration
there from both coaches and players that
they just weren't as committed to
everything had they've been in the past
and they were kind of waiting for the
playoffs to begin but in terms of drama
that's going to shock us that I don't
you know I didn't get any specific and
have any feel like that I I'm curious
you know hi Davis what David West said
you people don't know no you know we
don't know so so tell us yes just
throwing us out there you know we admit
we don't know I'm curious to what he
says it that West is one of the most
intelligent players in my 25 years in
the NBA a guy is he's he's got an
amazing perspective but I was surprised
he threw that out there because what
that does it just leads to speculation
which I don't think it happens very
often on Twitter
but but it just it's a little reckless
to do that because it makes everybody
want to speculate on what he was talking
about well yeah I mean cuz we're and you
having been around as you mentioned for
as long as you have and with with some
many many moons in New York City the
disease of more as Pat Riley always says
that that is what Tears a dynasty apart
and we're we're looking for the seams
and the fact that there could already be
some seeds that they were able to
overcome this year was the shocking part
Mike and the question is is just how
sustainable is that if you have been
saying that in these production means
you found that the regular season to
them was uh it was just a difficult
thing to to bridge from moment tip to
moment last what will next year look
like well it could go one of two ways
because by the end they were talking
about how facing these this type of
quote-unquote drama facing this
adversity actually brought them together
when it counted so it might be something
that actually strengthens them for next
year because they saw how it could
easily go awry and mean they were they
were basically one half away from from
losing to usun in two separate games so
they knew they were close to not getting
it so there could be something to
actually be a positive and strengthen
them or you know the disease of me is
Riley talked about can can become even
more so next year but it's not that
they're really not that kind of a group
they they they've all played the game
the same way their whole lives in terms
of yeah they're offensive Lee brilliant
but they love the team aspect and that's
even Duran who sometimes can get
involved in a little I so but I mean you
look what he did in the final this year
in terms of his assist total they all
love the ball movement they all love
working together so I don't think it's a
group that's gonna collapse in that way
but I think it's it's something to watch
for for next year especially if we find
out what David was talking about I think
you let mr. at a third option the people
are talking about Mike
it's possible or not that LeBron could
join the classic can you imagine that
the the hatred that would happen
everybody would he would become first up
he'd become the villain again but he
would be joined by the other villains
Angola state it'd be people that we just
want to want to see them get get taken
down I just I mean I don't know I'm my
guess is as much as anybody there's just
no way that's gonna happen well before I
let you go Mike as you know here on this
show last week we were able to pull back
the curtain on on something that Van
Gundy mentioned on your broadcast in
Game two of the NBA Finals that he went
to Yale with Jodie Foster and remembers
her and we had Jodie here on the show I
believe you know and she doesn't
remember Jeff Mike how did that go down
in your in your world well it you know
through such an embarrassment to happen
to our colleague and partner there was
nothing that could have made it a better
day for us we success joy in it because
you know you talked for years about his
friend Jodie Foster his classmate Jodie
Foster and then to have it finally
revealed that you know it was so
embarrassing much to the light of our
entire crew so we took great pleasure in
it in fact we would have if it was a
regular season came rest we would have
spent probably at least a full quarter
discussing it got to be honest with you
when garbage time hit right around the
mid third quarter I thought maybe just
maybe that this is this is garbage time
material and then I realized you know
there's that whole LeBron leaving
Cleveland thing and the Golden State
Warriors winning three and four years
thing that might have you know shoved
that a little bit further down your run
down but when you say Sherrod how did
you how did you share this video with
everybody is that you're saying like as
many people as we as time would permit I
mean we did it pretty much right up to
tip-off and so Steve Curren our free
game coaches meetings and she and he
enjoyed it as well
you know we had to balance between our
respect for the game and the finals and
what the moment meant and our delight in
embarrassed
Jeff and it was a very difficult choice
we were a little bit we were we were a
little bit conflicted Mike because we
showed a current photo of Jeff I don't
know if we could have unearthed a a
class photo of Jeff from Yale back in
the day if that would have helped do you
think that would have helped maybe Oh
without question he's changed in so many
ways throughout his life so she may have
recognized but to Jeff's defense yes
nobody laughed harder when they saw the
business that's great man that is just
good fun Mike thanks for for joining
great call once again on an NBA Finals
enjoy the the non playing season for you
because it's right around the corner the
NBA season next year my pleasure richer
always fun thanks both all right now
should we tuck you in should we read you
a book no I'm gonna go right back to
sleep
yeah warm glass of milk and a saucer no
not even needed take care Mike that's my
green here on the Rich Eisen show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience